في إسرائيل، واصل المتظاهرون
الضغط لعطلة نهاية الأسبوع السابعة والعشرين على التوالي
بسبب التغييرات القضائية التي اقترحها رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو، حيث
تظاهر مئات الآلاف في تل أبيب ومدن أخرى
يوم السبت، يمكنك فقط رؤية
حجم الحشود هناك التي
يعارضون مشروع القانون كما يقولون  يقيد
سلطة المحكمة العليا ويقوض
الديمقراطية، حيث تجمع الكثيرون
خارج منزل اثنين من
الوزراء، بما في ذلك وزير الدفاع
في شمال إسرائيل، ودعوه
للانضمام إلى المظاهرات في تل أبيب.
تستخدم الشرطة خراطيم المياه ضد الأشخاص الذين
يسدون طريقًا سريعًا رئيسيًا
تأتي الاحتجاجات  قبل القراءة الأولى المخطط لها
لمشروع القانون في الكنيست يوم
الاثنين، يقول الإسرائيليون إنهم قلقون بشأن
المستقبل